bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du nokia x6 nokia 10 prononcé moi je
lire nokia liste le nokia disque c'est
déjà dévoilé on en sait plus il va être
présenté d'ici quelques jours
donc pour l'instant ce qu'on va faire
pour faire un état des lieux des rues
d'heure on va regarder si l'économie
long et on y va
le nokia dit c'est le nouveau smartphone
milieu de gamme de nokia
alors nokia a présenté son produit déjà
il ya quelques temps lors d'un événement
on s'attendait à leur arrivée le 27
avril phrase de commercialisation fin
nouveau de présentation et il traîne y
traîne il attend il prend son temps et
non il devrait arriver le 16 mai le 16
mai c'est mal ces jeux mais ça vous dit
rien si vous vous souvenez bien réfléchi
c'est le 16 mai qu'est ce qui est le 16
mai voyez pas bon le 16 mai c'est la
date à laquelle one + va présenter son
nouveau smartphone haut de gamme le one
+ 6 alors c'est très intéressant et
c'est vraiment révélateur de la
stratégie nokia mais avant de parler de
stratégie on va parler un petit jeu
technique pour voir ce que ce nos
caddies sera dans le ventre alors on
sait déjà à quoi il va ressembler c'est
un smartphone avec une encoche sur le
haut à bord sur le bas des bords le g à
droite et à gauche
un grand écran un écran de 5,8 pouces
qui pourrait être un réflexe des plus au
format 19/9 o2i a trouvé un double
capteur photo au centre le flash en
dessous un capteur d'empreintes
digitales pour le déverrouiller un
design qui nous sommes en tout cas assez
proche du web et 20 p 20 light
je trouve qu'il ressemble assez très
très similaires côté puissance côté
processeur pour l'instant on n'en sait
pas plus parce qu'effectivement était
présente et il a pu être pris en main il
a pu être regardée mais bien évidemment
nokia avait pris soin de bloquer les
spécifications techniques qu'on ne
pouvait pas lire à l'intérieur donc on
n'en sait pas plus donc au point de vue
spéculation rumeurs et puis toutes les
petites à faucons à droite à gauche on
pense qu'on pourra voir sa dragonne 660
ou alors un médiathèque et llopez 60 il
tournait tout un androïde 8.1 8.0 oreo
il serait disponible dans un tarif
avoisinant les 210 à 240 euros hors
taxes donc peut-être un peu plus cher
dans l'hexagone par bien sûr pour les
français pour les belges les suisses et
tous ceux qui sont ailleurs pourront
probablement la boire un peu moins cher
talent maintenant moyens truc qui me
pose question parce que si on regarde
les images officielles qui nous ont été
fournies par les personnes quand ils
versent produits on voit sur la façade
au milieu un petit doigt d'empreintes
digitales sur l'écran alors ça me paraît
un petit peu dingue parce que on voit
d'un côté une caméra vous avez d'un côté
un téléphone on comprend qu'en appuyant
leurs blousons lente
prendre une photo on peut faire
effectivement passé un coup de fil
mais l'empreinte digitale parce que au
dos de l'appareil vous avez déjà un 14
au premier chef pour déverrouiller donc
moi très clairement quand je vois son
milieu je me dis sous l'écran il ya
quatre ans d'empreintes digitales
donc oui ça me paraît bizarre que nokia
à y mettre ça sur un produit milieu de
gamme
alors vous avez des produits haut de
gamme comme le nokia n86 roncq était
présenté en début d'année et que j'ai pu
prendre en main mwc à barcelone qui ne
l'avait pas pourquoi est-ce qu'on
retrouve cette icône là est ce que ça
veut dire pour avoir un capteur
d'empreintes digitales se positionner
sous l'écran ça me pose un peu question
ça soulève pas mal d'interrogations
avoir effectivement le 16 mai prochain
lors de la présentation officielle alors
nokia très malin du point de vue
marketing se porte donc plutôt bien joué
ils savent que même s'ils reviennent un
peu en grâce même si on parle un peu de
nokia souffre quand même ils ont eu
vraiment des années très très forte avec
souvenez-vous le 33 10 mais 33 disent
agir est vraiment of school of celui là
celui là pas la version de 2017 qui
était quand même assez moyenne va pas se
mentir
celui là alors qu'elle nokia banale
sortie qui était le le modèle qu'on a pu
voir dans matrix mais ça très clairement
c'était vraiment aux références de
produits nokia qui a cartonné
donc ils savent aujourd'hui nokia qui
sont pas encore suffisamment dans keable
par rapport à d'autres marques à des
marques comme moi non plus qui montre
vraiment qu'une vraie belle progression
ils sont pas encore très très fort alors
l'idée l'idée je trouve plutôt bonne de
se dire allez puisqu'on a préfère parler
nous on sait qu'on aura une couleur très
médiatique mais malgré tout est ce que
ça va vraiment intéressés de
consommateurs suffisamment fortement
donc pourquoi pas valence et cache le
produit avant même son annonce
officielle se ferment effectivement de
faire couler de l'encré
que les journalistes les influenceurs et
pas mal de monde puisse en parler le
reprendre aujourd'hui on s'est très
clairement à quoi va ressembler ce nokia
10 nokia x1 on le voit on le sait par
contre ça crée vraiment un désir est une
curiosité savoir ce qui va y avoir à
l'intérieur c'est comme si on vous donne
un bout de gâteau vous avez gâteau
devant vous mais vous pouvez pas le
manger
c'est un petit peu frustrant donc là on
sait à quoi il va ressembler mais on
sait pas du tout comment il a fonctionné
la puissance est ce qu'il va y avoir
dans donc sacré à mon avis le désir et
deuxième point est très intéressant
deuxième point de la part de nokia c'est
vraiment de l'annoncé
le même jour que wang plus de faire le
même jour que la présentation officielle
devant une + 6 parce que il aurait pu le
faire effectivement le 27 avril comme
tout le monde les attendait à voir
l'info directement
d'avril et ensuite on en aurait parlé ça
serait passé à l'astral y avait derrière
la très clairement le 16 mai tout le
monde va parler de one plus one + 6 dans
les médias spécialisés sur le web dans
la presse on en retrouve des articles
donc ya pas mal d'attentes
il ya des gens qui vont aller lire la
presse le 16 au soir et le 17 au matin
et en même temps si vous avez un article
sur nokia et sans aucun disque ça peut
permettre de gagner en visibilité et de
finir donner envie et je trouve que ça
c'est vraiment très intéressant parce
que il cherche vraiment à se diversifier
et à proposer quelque chose de différent
par rapport à ce que fait la concurrence
pour gagner en visibilité et pour que
les produits plus se voir et de toute
façon pour qu'un produit soit acheté il
faut commencer par le voir donc je
trouve que ça s'est vraiment bien pensé
la preuve en est puisqu'on en parle
aujourd'hui c'est que fondamentalement
ils ont fait la bonne stratégie le fait
de balancer le produit comme ça on peut
en parler on peut dire waouh mais c'est
quoi cette histoire
le produit est déjà disponible on peut
déjà le voir alors qu'il n'est même pas
commercialisé qu'il ait même pas annoncé
officiellement par nokia voilà dites moi
vous est-ce que ce nokia tu dises nokia
x pourrait vous intéresser
est ce que vous le trouvez cool a priori
pourrait s'appeler le nokia x6 le nokia
e6 le nokia x6 on a vu en tout cas sur
les publications de nokia c'est que les
marques et nokia 10 nokia x non c'est
pas plus sain c'est un petit peu de un
peu frustrant effectivement ne pas en
savoir plus donc du coup sacré désir
voilà donc dites moi ce que vous en
pensez vous marquez tout sans
commentaires questions suggestions vous
avez l'habitude je vous invite comme la
bm laisser des jolies pousse à vous
abonner vous allez voir apparaître
toujours plus de teck a plein de choses
qui arrivent plein de surprises plein de
bonnes infos plein de plaintes ou du
cool tout du ouf je j'arrive plus je
mélange les mots changent les français
merci à vous je vous dis à très bientôt
soyez sages
je vous embrasse et restez connectés
ciao
[Musique]